Mark Zuckerberg and Facebook are you
guys still on Facebook it seems like
it's lost a little bit a little bit of
its Jawad to be um he made Mark
Zuckerberg the creator or the guy who
stole Facebook whatever that whole movie
was about he made three point eight
billion dollars last week billion that's
billion with the be three point eight
billion dollars in one day because I'm
not even gonna get into specifics the
IPO on the stocks and blah blah blah
three point eight billion dollars one
man who created some computer thing that
I've never clicked an ad on and I don't
understand any of this is this complete
insanity like we're talking about a
number that is so out of the realm of
understanding is this just completely
nuts
well it isn't it isn't I mean it's it
has become a part it has become fully
the way that we communicate with each
other right now whether you're on that
thing or not he he owns he owns the
technology that allows us all to
communicate with one another now I don't
remember the last time I spoke on the
phone you know what I mean and even
though Facebook has lost a lot of its
luster and just it's it's become nothing
but my relatives posting things from the
daily current and thinking they're real
here I mean I think that what the daily
Kanaly current is is like it's like an
onion but like they were like let's like
let's be like the onion but not ever be
funny really and not do stories that are
sort of within the realm of plausibility
yeah and and and they do that and it is
like I'm gonna get sorry Michele
Bachmann and file for divorce or
whatever that's semi plausible it's not
real funny right yet it's all over my
freaking wall yeah but it's like like
oMFG can't believe this is happening I
guess today well it is going though yeah
yeah that and you know farm bill invites
or whatever but in a truly like it is he
is it it is the vehicle through which
all communication takes place now and so
much of your information your
preferences what you like you've allowed
other applications to access it that
therefore know what you like I think
that's really that people go what is it
worth everyone goes I don't click on
these stupid ads I think the ads are
like a false flag first of all the ads
just got
stupid suckers that heard you go to get
on the Facebook that art way to
corporate and old and out of touch to
understand it there's no reason to buy a
Facebook ad really ever right maybe to
bolster things to your page because you
want to get information out and get more
people to like your page that I
understand but just an ad you know just
oh come here and buy JCPenney jeans like
you're not going to win that way but
they have so many people have every
demographic from you know 15 year old on
up through you know my 69 year old
mothers on Facebook and she will write
my favorite food is this and I like this
and she will click on things that they
know what she's gonna click on and they
know what story she likes so it's
potentially interesting that the the
source of information you know people
hire marketing firms to you know they'll
give them millions of dollars to a
marking for him to try to figure out
what do people like into trend forecast
he is now built when the biggest trend
forecasters and predicted particularly
things that will show you what people
like and what they're engaging in yeah
that's the word writing ok well there's
the three client list more than anything
yeah so the 3.8 still seems crazy to me
that just seems like a number that is so
astronomical and out of the realm of
understanding even that that seems
bonkers but I think what you're hitting
on here and that I think is the scary
part is here he's really buying us what
he really owns now is a piece of all of
us and we just keep giving more pieces
of our shelves what what is it about us
that we all have this feel that we've
talked about this a lot on the show
about why we keep giving all this
information but what is it about humans
that we just keep givin away everything
and now the government is watching our
metadata and that whole thing and it's
like are we just gonna keep giving
everything away until we're just part of
the matrix you know honestly my parents
raised me never to give people your
information like always you know
somebody like calls up asking a question
or whatever hang up yeah yeah yeah but
now it's just like sure if you know if
you'll let me like write a blog post or
whatever I'll tell you everything about
myself or square you know you couldn't
even tell somebody where you were going
where you were where our house is
any information back when I remember
that you you never talk to strangers
don't say anything and you're right now
you're actually facebooking where you
are your for squaring checking in you're
saying all your preferences you're
actually listing your relatives how they
have the relative finder on Facebook
stores is your aunt is this person your
uncle is this person so we are a bit
though we're all aware of it and yet
we're willfully doing I'm literally
talking about the three of us yeah
one's doing it you got if you wrote what
everyone's doing if and how are you an
individual danger it seems more
palatable yeah so basically we shouldn't
I mean really it is scary it's because
it's a free service and now we feel he
can't live without it this funny people
thought I'd be like why I can't delete
my facebook how would I communicate with
people by don't have Facebook every day
yeah delete it all I want to do like
every area I'd wake up saying today's
the day and I just never one day Dave
one day all right well we're gonna post
this on Facebook and don't forget to
click like please we can eat those likes